as I keep joking we only find out what a
Labour party policy is when they
announce that they're no longer going to
do it uh and and I think they'll roll
back even on private schools and things
like that leading with nothing uh sunak
has tried to introduce the question of
trust and so his definition of trust is
me promising as little as possible but
convincing you that I can at least
deliver that starmer's version of trust
is I won't promise anything so you can't
be disappointed because I haven't
actually said I do anything uh and
I I just don't think that's very
exciting but I still suspect that he can
Coast into number 10 purely on
frustration and anger with the Tory
record